how important is that to know that like
because I have family members that have
been doing
I mean over 20 years in prison now and I
know that like any time
we write them or we accept the phone
calls is so important but I feel like
when you get incarcerated did you ever
feel like at certain points of time
you're kind of forgotten about when it
came to family friends whatever yeah but
it gets to a point where like you'd be
like [ __ ] don't nobody owe me no little
don't nobody owe me no phone call don't
nobody owe me no come see her I put
myself in this [ __ ] you know you
got to be a realist when when you when
that's that's all part of being a man to
me you know what I'm saying just being a
realist like you got to accept this [ __ ]
like you can't really feel like oh oh
I'm lonely [ __ ] you wanted to be lonely
you signed up for you knew what this
what came with this doing so you can't
even be if you do if you are lonely you
can't now the ones that do stay there
with you and do stick by your side them
the ones you got the cherish like
them the ones you got to really be there
for and they might not be perfect they
might have flaws you know what I'm
saying but at the same time like loyalty
overall so if a [ __ ] be loyalty
a lawyer if a [ __ ] can be loyal
then anything else you can kind of work
out with them like yeah you can work out
the rough part yeah loyalty I think is a
long that's the overall quality of the
hair like this it's as long as you loyal
you you are we can work we can work
around your other flaws that's fair you
know I'm saying this is my opinion when
it comes to this [ __ ] so that's how I
feel about like but yeah it gets [ __ ]
up it get longer it get yeah it's [ __ ]
up but you gotta the only thing that
kept me saying was man you did this [ __ ]
so you got to do what you got to do to
not ever feel this feeling right here
again hmm